hello everyone welcome to another HD
toriel in this video I'll be showing you
how to change the autoplay settings in
Windows Vista you may have a program
that every time you put it in the disc
maybe uh maybe windows asks you are you
sure you want to run this program are
you really sure
are you really sure so I'm just gonna
show you guys how real quickly you can
change the autoplay settings so what
you're gonna do is you pardon pardon
that blinking there click on your Start
menu and you're going to go to start
search and type in autoplay and the
first thing and I'll come up in Windows
Vista is a program autoplay just click
on it and it'll grapple it'll look like
Windows Explorer and it was actually the
how you get to it in the first place but
that was just a quick show you so this
is what you choose what you happen when
you insert just certain types of media
or maybe a USB or an audio CD or certain
stuff like that
so I have it set to whenever I put in an
audio CD BAM rip the CD audio using a
certain program I can take no action
I can always open the folders using
Explorer I can always open it up in
iTunes so this is a very convenient way
to choose exactly what one of those does
say I'm just put in a piece of software
I will open it install or run the
program maybe I put in a blank CD what
am I gonna do I chose it to ask me every
time sometimes I want to change things
same thing with HD movies superceding
video I mean all these things also my my
LG Voyager has its own little section
here the LG VX 10,000 I'm gonna say I
want it to manage this device using Rap
City and safe so now whenever i plug in
my LG voyager it will always always sync
app city ii i plug it in so that's very
convenient that's just that's basically
it that is how I chose chat choose sorry
can't really talk today this is how I
choose exactly what happens every time I
insert a new like external device maybe
if I had an expert Drive hooked up
install the drivers from an external
hard drive it would show up under
devices and I will be able to choose
exactly what happens every time I plug
it back in should I ever output it
so that's just a quick look for you guys
I hope you found it helpful
and if you have any tutorial requests
just go ahead and subscribe and send me
a message I'll get right to it for
watching guys peace